you made a Berkshire Hathaway forward
Buffett and they're insanely high stock
prices but what exactly is first I had
to wait and why is your stock price so
high make sure to stick around till the
end if you want to find out
[Music]
welcome to Haris hobbies so here's just
some quick history on the roots of the
company Berkshire Hathaway actually
started as two companies in the late
18-hundreds these were actually three
textile companies in Massachusetts what
was berkshire cotton manufacturing
company which is incorporated in 1889
and the other one was Hathaway
manufacturing company which is
incorporated in 1888 in 1955 these two
companies merged to create Berkshire
Hathaway Warren Buffett d'emic come into
picture until 1965 when an investment
company that he led took full control of
the company while they continued their
textile operations they are quickly
moving away from it and we're investing
in other companies and by 1985 all
textile operations of this company were
liquidated but by this time Berkshire
Hathaway is well established as
Buffett's holding company for other
investments and corporate acquisitions
Buffett mainly grew Berkshire Hathaway
by buying stock and undervalued
companies and eventually completed
buying them out while Warren Buffett
owned made these companies outright he
was very well known for long great
autonomy for managers of these
subsidiaries Buffett really had a taste
for insurance companies as insurance
companies made up a good chunk of
Berkshire Hathaway's investment
portfolio some of the most notable
purchases were Geico in 1996 and in
general or reinsurance in 1998 while a
company owns several insurance companies
they also like to keep it diversified at
the same time for example the acquired
Scott Patrick company in 1986 who is the
owner of reference and educational
publisher
world book and Fruit of the Loom in 2002
manufacturer of under clothing
one of the biggest acquisitions was the
Burlington Santa Fe and northern
corporation in 2010 who owned the BNSF
Railway for forty four billion dollars
despite having diversification in his
investment portfolio all of this
companies had one similarity there were
all very safe investments Berkshire
Hathaway investment companies have
almost always been drawn from
established markets as a post of
emerging markets this explains her
significant holdings in several fortune
500 companies like Coca Cola Apple and
American Express these are some of the
gems that Berkshire Hathaway owns for
example coca-cola stock has increased in
dividends for the last 55 years in a row
by investing in such safe and reliable
companies Warren Buffett was able to
build a huge investment portfolio that
is Berkshire Hathaway but the initial
stages of growth of a company are
usually very fast how was he able to
sustain such high volumes of growth for
such a long period of time
well for starters Berkshire Hathaway has
the biggest float in the entire world
floats refers to the money that
Berkshire Hathaway's insurance companies
upstairs have received as premiums but
are yet to be paid out as claims so
technically this isn't the company's
money but managers can invest this money
in ways that they see fit Berkshire had
to his float sits at over 100 billion
dollars and not only is this the biggest
in the world but what makes it even more
impressive is that just a generation ago
is 50 times less than that at just 2
billion dollars this vast amount of
money I lost Berkshire Hathaway to
quickly acquire dying companies and
revitalize them one of the best examples
of this is fruit of the Loom Berkshire
Hathaway bought fruit of the Loom for a
mere eight hundred and thirty five
million dollars in 2002 when the stock
had lost 97 percent of its value today
for Illume sells the highest quantity of
mint undergarments in the United States
their vast float is one of the key
reasons that they have been able sustain
such high growth first a long period of
time one of their other key reasons
for success is there a lack of dyndns
what's ironic about this is that Warren
Buffett is very keen on finding stock
that do pay him dividends but his own
stock doesn't pay out dividends
logically it does make sense to always
take the mind that other companies give
you and never pay out yourself but at
the same time it is - ironic Berkshire
Hathaway has actually pay out dividends
once in its lifetime in 1967 when they
pay out 10 cents a share but even to
this day Warren Buffett claims that he
must have been a bathroom when the
dividend was authorized this lack of
dividends a lot of companies spend this
money in other places to further grow
the company despite a lack of dividend
it would be very short-sighted of an
investor to shy away from Berkshire
Hathaway stock simply did that one
reason the stock price has skyrocketed
over the past 51 years in 1980 it was
275 dollars just 15 years later in 1995
it went up to thirty two thousand five
hundred dollars and today May 20th 2019
it costs over three hundred and two
thousand dollars this is a track record
without comparison as an investor the
choice is pretty straightforward would
you rather have a dividend payment or
would you prefer to see a team who took
a humble textile investment and turned
it into one of the largest most
respected and most financial robust
companies to date business for Buffett
hasn't always been rosy though in 1975
Buffett and his investment partner
Charlie Munger were investigated by
Securities and Exchange Commission SEC
for fraud the two maintained they had
done nothing wrong that the only reason
the perch of the Wescott Financial
Corporation looked suspicious
is just your complex system of
businesses further trouble came in 1991
with a large investment in
an Inc news broke of a crater of
breaking treasure bidding rolls on
several occasions only through intense
negotiations was Buffy able to stave off
a ban on buying Treasury notes and
subsequent bankruptcy from the firm
not only the warren buffett geishas own
company through several major setbacks
he helped many other companies get
through a rough times Buffett has act as
a financier and facilitator of major
transactions during the Great Recession
Warren Buffett lank invested money in
two companies that are facing financial
disaster roughly 10 years later the
effects of these transactions are
emerging and effects are enormous alone
to Mars Inc resulted in a six hundred
and eighty million dollar profit Wells
Fargo of which Berkshire Hathaway about
120 million shares during the great
recession as all-time low doesn't nine
is up seven times since then American
Express stock is up about five times
since Warren Buffett's investment in
2008 Bank of America Corporation pace
Berkshire Hathaway about three hundred
million dollars a year in Berkshire
Hathaway has the option of buying more
shares for just $7 apiece which is less
than half its current value and of
course goldman sachs pays out five
hundred million dollars in dividends a
year to Berkshire Hathaway and I also
offered a 500 million dollar redemption
bonus for repurchasing their shares ask
for more recent ventures brush' Hathaway
has partnered up with 3G capital to
merge JH Heinz and a craft food company
to create Kraft Heinz food company the
new company is a third largest food
company in North America and the fifth
largest food company in the world and
post an annual revenue of over 28
billion dollars in 2017 he by a
significant chunk of pilot Travel
Centers orders a pilot a chain of truck
stops
Berkshire Hathaway will become the
majority holder of this company in just
a six year time period so it is clear
while Warren Buffett Berkshire Hathaway
may have seen some trouble you're
obviously doing very well and growing
still at a very rapid pace
you may have wondered why Prussia
Hathaway stock is so expensive most of
you guys probably inferred or guessed
that simply because the company has yet
to been split into more stocks but why
has Warren Buffett not authorised it
class a split as of now well this answer
is to avoid speculation in day trading
and attract long-term investors
according to the dictionary speculation
involves training a financial instrument
involving high risk an expectation of
significant returns speculation can
cause inflation of stock prices due to
hide interest on specific stock stock
prices would suddenly increased it to
high interest place on them but once the
interest slowly fades away
the stock prices will plummet this is
similar to what happened with Bitcoin
just last year
Bitcoin value skyrocket as GPU miners
really wanted them and many people were
investing in it but as the fat that out
because value half in a matter of weeks
breaking a berkshire hathaway stock used
to garner a lot of attention to the
company and would make accessible to
hundreds of thousands of more people we
can most certainly inflate the stock
price creating a Miss representatively
high value Warren Buffett doesn't want
to deal with speculative prices and
prefers our Berkshire Hathaway remains a
significant investment he's afraid that
by studying a stock this will attract a
traders for a try make a quick buck he
is always viewed her hat to his
investors as partners of the company and
not just investors of a public company
as a result he wants them to stick
around and stay invested buying and
selling Berkshire Hathaway stock is a
big decision like going to college or
buying a house so you were like eh think
a lot before coming to a consensus and
you're more likely to base your decision
on what that stock will do over a long
period of time rather than what it will
do tomorrow or even the next hour but
considering that this stock is only
traded between 300 and 400 people a day
obviously not that many people prefer to
do so and that is exactly Buffett's
intention he wants long-term investors
who are dedicated and trust the company
he is looking for long-term investors
and a
entry price is a perfect way to track
that demographic
however Warren Buffett did authorize a
Class B split a couple of years ago that
made each stock valued at 138 of a full
stock the split was authorized to
prevent fund managers from setting up
mutual fund sort of like structure that
sells slices of class a stock
furthermore the lower price of the Class
B stock makes it suitable to gauge the
value of the market plus a stock is
simply too expensive and traded to
sparsely to make it a good candidate for
an effective indexed component but in
the end this is why the main Berkshire
Hathaway stock is so expensive Warren
Buffett on the other hand doesn't act
like a billionaire and it stays far away
from my lavish lifestyle he takes a very
modest salary of $100,000 when
considering how much the value he has
created he takes to join the simplest
things in life such as EDI McDonald's he
still arrived himself to work every
single day in a used car and lives in a
very humble house that he bought decades
ago in 1958 for $31,500
he has pledged most of us wealth charity
and is very encouraging of people trying
to invest and create a better life for
themselves
well the Berkshire Hathaway has humble
beginnings after 40 years of strategic
acquisitions and efficient
problem-solving Warren Buffett's work
has results in a global conglomerate
without match that stays true to
smartest roots make sure to comment down
below what company you would like me to
cover next
and make sure drop a like if you enjoyed
this video also make sure subscribe if
you'd like some more videos just like
this one 5 till then I'm Hardy I'll see
you guys on the next one
[Music]